even from singers even from male singers
you hear so many songs that men sing
about how they messed up and they did
something wrong I can't think of a
single pop song written by a woman about
how like she wasn't good enough for the
guy she was with you get a lot of songs
like that written by male pop stars
I'm trying to think of one yeah now and
you see this Trope in film and
television all the time it's always the
guy begging the girl to come back to him
because he messed up holding the stereo
yeah and then it's trench coat while it
rains baby come back and yeah it's it's
never the opposite it's never the
opposite movies typically follow two
tropes one it's the guy saving the girl
or two it's the guy apologizing to the
girl
for women women
This Woman's like 90. she had a whole
family with another I know she's evil
and she's still talking about her
ex-lover she met for like a lover
whatever her one night stand no this is
a homeless guy it was two nights no but
this is very real right the Titanic is
an unbelievably Evil film but there's
something masterful about the way that
the cinematography the framing and the
music is used to make you sympathize
with someone who's a genuinely bad
person like she doesn't have a character
Arc she doesn't go from a bad person to
a good person she goes from like a
selfish person to a person who's like a
selfish person but who's selfish in a
different way and when you look I just
want to mention one thing what she does
I saw this movie years ago so you know
take this with a grain of salt but what
I remember is she cheats on her fiance
and then has the homeless guy she's
cheating on him with draw a picture of
her naked wearing her engagement gift
and then she puts it in his safe with
like a snide remark right now like that
psychopath behavior that is not what a
normal person does that is insane and
people watch this they're like wow her
story is inspiring she's a demon wasn't
she like talking to her granddaughter or
something she was on the boat and then
no no no no she was talking to treasure
Hunters who were looking for the diamond
she had which she throws off the boat
she's at a boat that cost millions of
dollars hundreds of thousands of rent
and they're asking her to tell this
boring old lady story she only tells
because they think she has a diamond and
she has it and she throws it off this
she hasn't given to the people who
listen to her for hours she doesn't sell
it to take care of her her granddaughter
who spent her life caring for her and
doesn't have a family of her own she
throws it off the ship because Jack
needed it
died in the bottom of the ocean
she was on the boat she was on the
safety boat right and she jumps off the
safety boat back into the real belt Jack
would be alive if she just stayed in the
original safety boat that saves her
later exactly right he there would have
been rumors and there was room on the
door dude they don't tell you the report
of the story but I bet you I bet you
jack when he saw she's almost still on
the boat was like
yeah no I can save both of us I can say
but yes fine just come just but I think
uh uh they've proven now that uh who's
the guy who did the movie what's his
name James Cameron yeah Cameron they he
did a thing where they got the two
people to sit on the door and it worked
and they're like yeah that was like you
know that was weird you know what other
movies like this too The Notebook I
remember being a kid watching this movie
and thinking like he's
like why is this okay yeah and they
romanticized cheating but you know what
I think it is I think it's like what's
that one about I don't know the notebook
basically she it's Again The One That
Got Away which is also a Katy Perry song
right but basically she dates this guy
in high school and they're in love or
whatever and then she they break up I
don't remember why but she goes on to
meet this really nice guy that like
treated her well all this stuff similar
you know to the Titanic but she just
couldn't get the old guy out of her head
and then she goes and cheats on him for
like three days and then he like runs in
the rain and is like I love you and then
she leaves her fiance for this guy she
dated in high school she's in Alpha
Widow bro
I actually never saw it but I had a
podcast guest who was explaining the
plot of it to me I was like this is this
is horrible yeah horrible Story the
alpha the alpha Widow is like it's it's
really common in music and movies can we
do like a sequel to every Hallmark movie
ever where it's like so the woman who's
got a fiance and he's like a snooty
business man and then she goes back home
to see her parents and then there's the
the nerdy guy who's all grown up in
Suave and he's like a carpenter now and
he's ripped and then he's very nice to
her and she realized he was the one all
along can we just have like a part two
where it's like they had a one night
stand and he was like yo I'm done like I
got things to do yeah I've seen you in
20 years later produce it I'll be I'll
act yeah no this happens
right every human being has a tendency
to wonder is the grass greener on the
other side and what Hollywood has done
is built an entire sub-industry of
telling women yes it is actually go to
the other side go check it out no it's
gonna be great you're gonna love your
time over there and then you end up uh
Divorced with a broken family or with a
person who actually doesn't treat you
very well and this isn't a dress then we
just keep churning out media that's
horribly irresponsible it should just be
like the day after she gets the the
hometown hero guy and she leaves her
snooty businessman fiance he like wakes
up and he's like I think you should
probably go and she's like what do you
mean I thought we were having
something's like no I was just saying
that so that you'd sleep with me you can
leave now but why why would Hollywood
producers want women to think the
hard-working man who's loyal to them is
bad for trying to stop weird strangers
from sleeping with her why would
Hollywood producers want women to have
that in their head I keep saying
Hollywood but it's Hallmark Hollywood
Hallmark all of it but I think made in
Canada Hallmark is like way over the
line but all of these Hollywood movies
follow similar tropes like the man who
meets all of society's standards for
what a responsible man is isn't good
enough we either depict him as being
like you know bad in some emotional way
you know there's there's always a catch
the good hard-working man always has
problems and like The Lovable loser
always has a heart of gold and genuinely
cares for you it's like sorry no well
and the other thing is like whenever
they always try to like explain women's
cheating so like whenever you say oh she
cheated they always say well why did he
cheat what did he do it's the same thing
if she freaks out and is like hitting a
guy it's always like what did he do what
did he do to deserve this like they're
the default is he deserved this in some
way where it's like if a man cheats he's
a dog he's evil he's just you know
whatever yeah but like here's here's the
thing like now we're seeing all of these
polyamorous relationships because
cheating kind of only really applies to
marriage and what we've created now is
this pseudo hybrid dating marriage thing
so here's how it used to be it was a a
young woman would date several men what
does that really mean it means they'd go
out for a cheeseburger and a milkshake
and then if they were like Hey we're
really getting along and we have a lot
in common this is fun they would decide
to get married now dating is first you
meet at a bar and then you bang at her
place or his place then they decide hey
maybe we should do this more often so
you've already like jumped the line into
like living together and hooking up but
there's no actual commitment so it's all
just
a mishmash yeah exactly so so what is
cheating well cheating was like you were
married marriage is a contract the
reason it's called cheat is because you
have a commitment you are breaking if
you're just like randomly dating some
floozy or something like how is it
cheating if you don't have anything
formally set anyway and you could leave
at any time well I would add one thing I
would say like if you are dating someone
monogamously to discern marriage and
they can't be monogamous through the
courtship process that does tell you
something about them it's like all right
yeah you're not the one for me yeah but
I mean from from your standard Sheamus
they're like the person you're dating is
not going around having sex with a bunch
of dudes no it's also true yes so
there's not at least if she does I don't
know about it
what are you saying like if you're if
you would never date a woman like that
if you're so dating a woman is like
you're going out for dinner and you're
going to the movies and then one day you
find out she went out to a movie with
Ian and I would be I would be like your
first movie
they're going to see what is a woman and
I'm like apparently a liar and a cheater
I could tell Matt Walsh what a woman is
if you were in a relationship with or if
you just met a girl that just rocked you
knocked you on your ass awesome but then
you found out she did it with 100 other
guys would you still be like whatever
I'm going for it there's a good question
so
um statistically speaking we know that
the more sexual partners a person has
the higher the probability that they
will end up being divorced so I would
say there's kind of an imprudence in not
considering a person's history uh 100 is
a very big number I think like someone
can make mistakes genuinely repent and
then do the hard work to try to do the
Penance in fasting and prayer to
straighten themselves out and become
like a good holy person who would be a
worthy mother to one's children but um I
mean after a hundred I think that's
going to be pretty difficult I'm not
saying it's impossible but uh I'm I'm
saying that it's not something that
shouldn't be considered and I think
there are a lot of people want to argue
that that shouldn't be considered and it
should yeah it's like do you decide with
your brain or with your heart you the
thing you have to think about and this
is this isn't me speaking as a married
man because I'm not married but I was
recently speaking to uh Jason Evert who
is and talks about these things and I
asked them a similar question is it
Jason is it ever I think it's ever yeah
he went to my high school really he
talked to your high school yeah he did
he did he's selling women dreams that
man yeah yeah I I yeah
I do like him but that's only
Trope with like the religious people
it's always like the ran through check
and like the guy that was a virgin that
like marries her at the end and she only
really gets away with it typically
because she's hot so which it's kind of
sad yeah that's a fair representation
I mean that's what happened like he's a
nice guy but oh that's what you're
saying no I I think that's a horrible
thing to say about him and his wife well
no I'm saying like that's what he said I
mean I don't I don't know like I'm not
trying gonna make it a personal thing
but can I can I finish basically like
that's what like the wife goes up first
and she talks about how she was like
slept with all these people and then the
guy goes up and talks about how he
didn't and then the girl like gets
married at the end and yeah that's it's
always the same thing like so the girl
basically gets ran through and then the
guy marries her after and I'm like it's
kind of selling dreams and like an
attractive girl can get away with it but
like the average check it's like but
what but but I think there's an
important contextual difference which is
that Jason and his wife aren't saying
like go do this and it'll be fine what
they're saying was like this was a
horribly damaging thing to do she wished
she had never done it and she repented
and got close to Christ and like did the
work to undo her scars and if it's
genuine sure but I just think like the
the issue like why I think a lot of
times Church like attracts women that
like hat like that are a bit slug I mean
come on like let's just be honest like
there's a reason there's Catholic girls
have a reputation there's a reason
Church girls have a reputation well I
think because most people who are
supposedly raising the faith aren't
they're told their Catholic and they
don't go to church they don't well I I
think it's too because like the church
kind of sells them dreams that you can
do all this stuff and still have a guy
waiting for you at the end and like now
and the data just doesn't support it
it's like 50 of women are going to be
single and childless I see what you're
saying it very much sounds like the life
of sin followed by a deathbed repentance
of Christianity no no no no because
there's a difference there's like and
this is one of the distinctions you have
to make and part of why I brought up
Jason Everett is because what he said to
me when I asked him this question on air
was the question you need to ask
yourself is like what could you tolerate
10 years from now in a relationship with
this person and that is going to be
partially defined by that person's
wounds the things that they've done in
their past so a person having
a very unfortunate sexual history
doesn't just or even necessarily mean
that they're going to cheat on you or be
promiscuous they could end up being
monogamous and faithful but they could
still end up having all sorts of scars
with respect to the way they view sex
with the way they view the opposite sex
they can become an angry nasty person
because of it and you want to know that
there's someone who has worked through
it there's no denying that it is better
to be a virgin right but not everyone is
and God calls people to marry
non-virgins as well well yeah but I
think my point is that it's like they
just sort of like I think sometimes the
church sort of sells the dreams to women
because it's like you're kind of asking
a guy like to me something that's a bit
unreasonable like he why would he wait
when you slept with x amount of men like
for free well I think and I never and I
never see the church like like really
calling out like hey do not marry women
that aren't virgins I've never heard
like do not like they're red flag if she
slept with this many people I've never
really heard that so it's interesting
like they'll I really don't no no well
there's a couple different things to
pull apart there I mean firstly uh your
CR I mean I've never heard anyone say
don't marry a a non-virgin
how could they yeah in this day and age
that's just that's not so much a church
thing as much as that is like this is
something people won't say one thing we
do believe in is repentance and that a
person can restore themselves with the
help of Christ uh God can restore people
if you cooperate with him but
I I would add one detail which is that
it doesn't say like men stay a virgin
women sleep around and then get married
it tells everyone to remain a virgin and
it will also tell women by the way that
like the man you're with uh he might
have slept around he might like have had
struggles with a porn addiction they
struggle with it the issue is real the
issue is though like women have so much
more like like obviously power on the
sexual market like there's so much more
opportunity to do it from a young age
right so you're going to have women that
have slept around and men that are a bit
naive and they don't know how to like
like if you have a guy that's a virgin
and a woman that slept with I don't know
like however many people right like he's
going to be naive and he won't really be
able to pick up on like certain red
flags I think I know I look I think
there's some truth and I think the
church doesn't really talk about like
the the baggage like they don't really
like talk about the baggage that comes
with this stuff and like warning men
about predatory women because there are
predatory women I totally agree with you
look I totally agree with you that there
are predatory women I think it's a big
statement to say the church doesn't warn
people about this because I know plenty
Catholics uh plenty of Catholics who
would say like yeah stay a virgin try to
marry a virgin I also know others who
would say it's important to be yeah I
know nice well and I also know people
who would say it's good to be equally
yoked right like yeah if you don't think
you could handle that if you're a virgin
and this person uh has slept with a lot
of people that that is something you
consider in your discernment it's not to
say like you're evil because you don't
want to marry someone who's not a virgin
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time